and now a guy on the mound who has the
heart of a lion when he is pitching just
position of a panda when he's off the
mound he is an interesting cat deep
thinker and ready to go
swinging a grounder toward the holy
short backhanded by willie had a little
trouble getting out of his mid throws
the first in the dirt picked by jimmon
choi oh it's a spectacular play by g-mon
choy at first base willie threw off
balance across his body and bets as you
know gets up the line very well now
turner's stepping in
216 11 for 51. turner swings and sends a
bowl to deep left and that one is gone
a first inning homer and more postseason
franchise history for the dodger third
baseman justin turner good hitters make
little adjustments and on a 1-2 pitch
for morton trying to come back start the
ball inside
and to get turner come off the plate
well that ball just drifted in and
turner turned on it bueller is rapidly
establishing himself
in his young career as really one of the
game's elite post-season pitchers now
brandon lau
perfect pitch over the outside corner
and that breaking ball was tight
and sharp
and his first strikeout swung on foul
tipped it into the glove of barnes a one
two three inning
for walker bueller striking out two
seeger at third turner at second he's
got a couple of extra base hits and here
is muncie in an infield single this
first time on c
bangs a base hit into center field
seeger will score and turner is right
behind it
max muncie a two out single to center
and the dodgers take a three to nothing
lead well you had a base open and right
handed hit her on deck and muncie is so
patient and so selected at the plate it
was going to be tough to retire
walker mueller the first two innings has
struck out four and thrown just 22
pitches
ground ball left side turner stabs it
he's played some great defense and
muncie on the other end
old twinkle toes muncie zanino in the
post season 182 8 for 44. playing on the
line drive one hop stab beauty by turner
throws the second on the first double
play it was a glove save by a goaltender
only was the third baseman turner who
begins a spectacular double play five
four three
no runs no hits no errors nobody left so
it's first and third
comes austin barnes struck out looking
his first time and now morton wants the
ground ball and there it is the punt
run scores
can't stop it i'm telling you and it's
four to nothing on a perfect punt by
austin barnes and just the third
sacrifice of this postseason
and even though he showed it john on the
first pitch that boat was so good
there's nothing troy could do bench for
the ground ball base head into center
field grounding third is peterson and he
will score as the dodgers take a five to
nothing lead top middle and bottom of
the dodgers order have
done the job so far first time either
team was no hit for four innings in
back-to-back games since 65. strikes out
swinging a 97 mile an hour fastball
that is the sixth strikeout of the game
for bueller swings and lines went fair
down the third base line and into the
corner the rays have their first hit
over to go dig it out as peterson around
first on his way to second is marco and
he'll get in there standing with a one
out double well that was needed now they
got one out of the way and it's an extra
base head here in the fifth and some of
the man at second base here's willie
swings and drives one down the left
field line it's fair and the corner will
go marco will round third he will score
adamus on his way in the second base
he's got an rbi double razor on the
board it's 5-1 well adamus needed that
so did tampa bay but willie six for 45
this postseason prior to that
austin barnes is struck out
sacrificed and knocked in a run and
there's a fly ball to left field well
hit it's got a chance and it's gone a
home run
austin barnes his first home run of the
post season
and the dodgers take a six to one lead
and now mike zenino leading it off he
strikes out swinging 95 miles an hour
eight strikeouts for bueller first out
of the six hung on and miss strike three
strikeout number nine for walker bueller
third time wow is down on strikes and
there's two out struck him out and that
is ten on the night the dodgers have put
up six runs on nine hits but the story
tonight is that guy and the raids are
down to the final out rosarina trying to
keep it going for g-man choi on deck his
thrill down the left-field line if it
stays fair it's good it is out of here
and randy arose arena is
furthered his record-setting 2020 post
season his eighth home run this fall
and that ties him with carlos beltran
nelson cruz and barry bonds for the most
in a single post-season run troy swings
and lines one to left right there is
taylor and the dodgers win the game six
to two take a two games to one lead